hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on fortnight again but this
time I was checking out the fortnight
Intel website and I found a few things
about potential new weapons coming to
fortnight Battle Royale or it might be
save the world there is no confirmation
on what is what it just shows what is in
the data files when a new patch launched
so let's get starting to read it out so
this first one is going to be about
upcoming weapons and some of the few
weapons that they found where this
legendary tactical assault rifle
basically it's an assault rifle weapon
fully automatic flexible assault rifle
capable of handling all types of combat
scenarios a high rate of fire with a
solid accuracy while aiming down sights
and fired in controlled bursts now on
this website they do have a PvP database
for how much damage and weapons speed
and all that stuff how much it is so
I'll likely read that out this weapon
does about 24 damage with a 3.5 fire
rate a 20 bullets a 2.9 reload speed so
compared to a gold scar it does about a
third of its damage with a little bit
slower fire rate and a little bit of a
less magazine but a longer reload time
so compared to a gold scar you
definitely want to pick up the gold scar
as opposed to this but charging off the
picture it is suppressed so that can
definitely help you in a suppressed
scenario overall I think the weapon
looks good I don't know how this will be
if this is actually in-game like I said
but if it is I feel like it might not be
overpowered and since it is a legendary
drop it is a pretty rare drop to get in
the game
so maybe who knows I like to know what
you guys think about this next up is is
a explosive crossbow this is going to be
a purple or epic tier it is pretty
simple just a normal crossbow with an
explosive tip so I'm assuming once it
lands or whatever it happens to hit
it'll explode I feel like this might be
in the save the world or if it's going
to be in for tonight Battle Royale it's
only going to be for a limited time
seeing as we already have a crossbow as
opposed to the tactical assault weapon
which is not even close to any weapon in
the game either way going off what it
says it's going to be 79 damage with
0.06 fire rate with a 5 magazine in a
2.4 7 second reload time going based off
what it says it seems like it's going to
be a normal crossbow except it's going
to be doing a lot more damage only
reason it's going to be doing that much
damage is probably cuz the explosive tip
at the very end of it either way think
the weapon is really cool
I don't know if it'll be in the game
like we said
I see the crossbow is already in the
game I don't think they'll add a
explosive version of it but that's cool
to know regardless next up is a p90 this
is going to be a rare tier or blue tier
it is a machine pistol fires a very high
rate dealing great damage while
consuming a lot of ammo good for run and
gun combat and a cure enough to fight a
mid range real fire in the short bursts
so similar to an actual p90 in any type
of video game that I have played this is
similar to how a p90 will operate so I'm
glad this is how it's supposed to be
going based off the damage chart from
the website it says that it can do 14 to
16 or 15 damage I'm assuming that's
different type of rarities so I'm
assuming there's probably going to be a
common one that does 14 a maybe a green
one that does 15 and a blue one that
does 16 is a 24 fire rate a 50 wrong
clip in about two seconds of a reload
speed so comparing that to a suppressed
SMG it's going to be a little bit faster
have a bigger clip and just about the
same reload speed with just a little bit
less damage I feel like that's going to
be fitting pretty well compared to the
other SMGs in that category I'm probably
going to assume that it's going to be
faster than the tactical SMG since the
p90 has always been a thing for having
fast fire rate let me you guys know what
you guys think about that but let's get
on with the new with the other weapons
and then the last weapon for this page
we still have a couple more pages to
look at but for the last weapon we have
the heavy shotgun it's supposed to be
legendary and epic this is the first
shotgun that's going to be a orange or
purple tier besides the purple tech of
course but other than that we don't
really have any other shotguns in the
game the heavy shotgun is a pump shoddy
with a larger mag fire slug rounds for
medium-range effectiveness going off
this it says it's supposed to have about
74 to 77 damage with a 1.25 fire rate
with an 8 Meg with an 8 Matt clip in a 7
second reload time going based off what
this says this seems to be a very very
deadly shotgun I don't know how well
this is going to be against the tactical
shotty if it's going to be any better
I'm assuming it is and compared to the
pump obviously if you have a green pump
who won all shots to the head do about
238 damage so I mean I have no clue how
this heavy shotguns going to play out I
feel personally that this is a bit too
overpowered for a fortnight Battle
Royale
so they might just put it any
save-the-world mode like I said these
weapons could be in Battle Royale
that could be in save the world that
could be in both this is just from what
the game files had and it's hard to
differentiate what's going to be in what
next up for the page of weapons we have
a automatic shotgun and precision rifles
and a bunch more coming to fortnight
Battle Royale as it says by this post
like we said there is no confirmed
confirmation if this will be in save the
world or for my battle royale or both
but continuing on we have a legendary
shotgun called the auto shot e it is a
shotgun automatic far as a wide spread
of pellets at an extreme fire rate can
decimate crowds at a significant mo cost
this seems to remind me of the aa12 if
any of you played the older Call of
Duty's and you know what the aa12 is
that seems to be right down the alley of
what this weapon is for the damage
values it says three point three with a
four fire 820 round mag in a three point
six reload speed I don't really
understand three point three that might
mean something three times the how many
pellets are shot so it could be nine if
all pellets lined I'm not entirely sure
because that doesn't seem entirely
correct to have a three damaging shotgun
yes it does have a lot of fire rate and
you do shoot a lot of stuff a lot of
pellets very quickly so that might be
the case either way the shotgun looks
really nice I'm not entirely sure how
this is going to fit into fortnight
Battle Royale since actually the next
weapon is another shotgun and we and
then with that going off this video we
have like five shotguns in total into
the game that's a crazy amount but going
on like I said we have another epic and
legendary tier shotgun called the
break-action shotgun do is high damage
at a fast fire rate short range and very
limited magazine size this looks but
like a double-barrel shotgun right away
the damage value is thirteen point two
for both of them a four fire rate a two
magazine size and a three point three
eight now reload speed comparing this to
the tax shot ease this seems to be doing
more damage has a faster fire rate a
less of a mag and also a slower reload
speed so this might be in one of those
situations where it's very up closing is
a double-barrel shotgun you definitely
want to make sure you hit your shots
because you're gonna have to be
reloading a lot but overall the weapon
does it look really nice I'm not like I
said not entirely sure if this will fit
into fortnight Battle Royale since we
have so many shotguns next up weapon is
called the hammer crush this seems to be
an assault weapon but a slug on a rifle
that fires slugs but the high damage and
impact good accuracy of the relative
ease
rate of fire and hyperbolic cost this
seems to be similar to the KSG in the
Call of Duty games basically it's a slug
round so instead of having a shotgun
that spreads the KSG shoots one single
slug straight forward similar to a gun
similar to an actual type of assault
rifle going off the damage supposed to
be 7.4 with a 1.5 fire rate and eight
magazine size and a 5.7 reload speed
the next two are LMGs these are going to
be the light machine gun and the m249
saw the light machine gun is a light
machine gun a heavy weapon with high
damage and extreme rate of fire and a
huge magazine size very inaccurate
unless aiming down sights from a fixed
position and fired in short bursts and
the m249 saw is hydraulic a slow firing
high-impact automatic rifle with a large
magazine size going off the damage
between the two it seems that the m249
saw is going to be having is going to be
a lot more damage but a slower fire rate
compared to the light machine gun for
some one reason the light machine gun
does not have a type of magazine size as
displayed on the website I don't know if
that means anything or if that is
because it's like the minigun where it's
kind of infinite and you just pick up
light bullets possibly you just keep
shooting with no reload speed I have no
clue what that means and it seems like
the light machine guns are going to have
a little bit of a faster reload speed
compared to the m249 saw and then lastly
to end the weapons for this is going to
be the precision assault rifle very
similar to the g36c in multiple
different games or that be Rainbow six
or Call of Duty it looks exactly like it
it is a burst assault rifle that fires
type burst allows for precision
targeting and mobile mid-range
engagements deals good damage but it
consumes the magazine very quickly and
that's going to be epic rare and
uncommon Tier four then for the damage
it seems to be three but I'm assuming
that's going to be three per bullet
possibly so that might be nine damage it
seems a little bit low for a precision
rifle but who knows it's going to have a
thirty round clip with a 5.5 fire rate
and about a 2.2 reload speed on average
for these weapons overall this seems
pretty nice we don't really have too
many burst rifles in the game obviously
the only one we have is the burst rifle
so that is kind of nice that we're
getting that we could possibly get a
different type I'll be all down for
burst rifles I'm a big fan of bursts or
flows as much as I hate them because I'm
very bad with them I'm always down to
have a burst rifle fight let me know
what you guys think about these weapons
in the comments below if do you think
that there if you
certain weapon will not be in for
tonight Battle Royale or if it's going
to be and save the world or if it
couldn't be in bolt Bluffton air
comments and then the last three weapons
that we have to look at are the remote
explosives device a stink bomb and the
egg launcher the egg launcher seems like
it's going to be the one weapon that'll
actually be in for tonight probably
confirmed seeing as it's almost near
Easter time when that comes in April or
toward the end of March and they usually
like to change the rocket launcher and
the grenade launcher to fit that type of
theme for the Halloween stuff they
changed the rocket launcher to a pumpkin
and then for the Christmas stuff they
changed the grenade launcher to shoot
snow balls so it's probably going to be
shooting eggs this time I think that's
really cool but that seems to be one of
the most confirmed ones personally to me
and the next - like I said our
explosives device in a stink bomb the
stink bomb might actually be in place of
the smoke grenade because if you watched
my video - from yesterday
it basically said that the smoke grenade
is going to be back in the vault because
they need to fix some internal testing
with it it doesn't seem to be operating
the way that they wanted to so they
might actually change it in place of a
stink bomb and it says it holds a
grenade that unleashes a cloud of poison
so better clear out that seems like it's
going to do similar damage to the storm
how the storm will tick will take your
health down if you're within it it's
probably going to be the same in terms
of how much damage it does I have
absolutely no clue it was not showing on
the storm shield one type of damage
value so I can't get an exact damage
output of how much these how much the
stink bomb will do and then they remote
explosives device or c4 seems to be a
really interesting idea it basically
toss out an explosive at a short range
the charge will explode if it takes any
damage and the secondary fire is
detonate all place charges so this can
be used in multiple ways you could
either throw down one c4 and then
detonate it immediately or you can just
throw it on a bunch around the house
maybe you're trying maybe you're in a
1v4 situation and you're kind of on your
last legs of hope and then an entire
team rushes into your building you have
a bunch of c-4 planted down and you blow
up the roof sky-high and you can kill
that whole team I don't know obviously
how many explosive devices are going to
beginning it is a rare type so maybe
like two or three but that is going to
be end of the video today guys I can
leave the website in the description
below if you guys want to check
everything out for yourself they usually
it seems like they update this stuff
daily on type of on new types of things
that they find so this is going to be
pretty interesting to check out but like
I said boys it's gonna be the end of the
video like the V if you did enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover
fortnight leaks data leaks all this type
of stuff I also I'm also going to be
start doing guides and tips to make
everybody a better player once I'm
probably going to be doing guides for
the four new weapons that come out like
say for example one of these weapons
comes out like the precision rifle I'll
do a guide on how to use that and how to
most to be effective with it if that
happens to release same with the other
weapons of course my two most recent
videos are gonna be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out with that
guys hope you have a great rest your day
peace out